okay good morning checking in I'm in my morning
uniform which is my green comfy which I actually
just washed which is amazing I hardly wash this
thing but I wear it all the time sorry just
checking to see how my stomach is doing what we do
all day long it's just like little body checks we
are oh it's upside down we're putting together
some liquid IV for herself it's Monday it's
Monday morning every morning we give ourselves a
dope girl bottle of liquid IV and some coffee if
we're filling up to it tada crystals haven't
dissolved that's fun nice and gritty tasting
and a little bit of coffee I've noticed that
after infusions for the first like week or so
my body doesn't want coffee which is devastating
it deems it gross so sad cuz I love coffee in the
morning as a ritual and as caffeine now finally
I'm about almost 2 weeks out from infusions and
my body wants coffee in the morning and that's
very exciting 9:46 a.m. today we'll see how the
vlogging goes this week I've already forgotten
to do it all last week so I picked up the camera
today as a way to just get it going today we are
going to get an echocardiogram is that how you say
echo cardiogram basically I have to get my heart
checked because these medications can mess with
your heart I have to go get a little heart check
to make sure this thing is pumping correctly and
it's really no big deal it's like 45 minutes
however it is it's just like this whole thing
is very awkward as someone who's pretty reserved
in their body naturally it really forces you to
shed all of those walls and just like give your
body over to science basically go into a room
strip off from the waist up and you just lay on
a table while they measure your heart for like a
half hour to 45 minutes so we're going to go get
half naked in a room with a stranger to make sure
that I'm surviving well through this process ooh
big Monday what else is there to report just a
lot of fatigue and a lot of gut stuff this time
around my stomach has not settled for weeks now
so we're still trying to eat a very boring bland
diet which is so boring and so Bland but it's for
the betterment of our body we've already eaten
an oatmeal and a banana this morning life is
wild over here oh look how bright lit up by
my Dashboard Light anyone hungry I got some
meatloaf we are in the parking lot of C sin and
we are going to go get an echo cardiogram going
to say Echo cardigan which sounds like a Taylor
Swift song we're going to go take our shirt off
girls gone wild and get our heart checked girls
gone healthy we're a little early so we can take
our time which is great this is a new era of my
life too where um I've been way oh there's someone
walking you're just a normal adult woman vlogging
in her car which is pretty normal these days I am
a bit in a new era of my life where I'm early
for things occasionally that's never happened
for years and years I was always late and running
high anxiety of being late constantly just putting
around panicking before I had to go somewhere and
now I'm early so I can just sort of like [Music]
sit don't be afraid of wet moist dirty things
don't be afraid to get your hands dirty don't
be afraid to have a dirty mind don't be afraid
to have lascivious thoughts don't be afraid to
have obscene thoughts don't be afraid of things
that are future oriented and don't be afraid
of spontaneity spontaneity doesn't mean being
Reckless it is Tuesday you know what that means we
sit in our car H in the parking lot getting ready
to go into therapy because we got here early I
don't really have anything else to say it's a very
full parking lot and people are driving around
looking for a spot and I don't want to give them
the illusion that I'm leaving no no I just got
here a little early cuz I'm doing a Great era of
arriving early to appointments but I'm still too
shy to just go sit around in the waiting room so
instead I'll wait in my car little by little but
otherwise I'm doing well today feeling a little
bit better I have had I'll tell you diarrhea
like crazy for the last 2 weeks all day every day
finally I told my doctor cuz I was like this can't
be normal I understand there's diarrhea associated
with cancer but this is excessive and now I have
to take two em modium every 2 hours today block
it up okay they're looking for spots I got to go
oh post therapy no tears today still good session
but no crying my therapy has variety hello it's
later in the evening on Tuesday mayry and I just
finished podcasting for the week over Zoom it was
delightful and also we had maybe one of the more
more in-depth conversations we've ever had on the
podcast a conversation about modern feminism and
our lives as it correlates that said um I turned
this on cuz I wanted to show you something as you
can see we readed our kitchen cabinets I haven't
done a full like reveal of it cuz I haven't
done a cooking video but do you want a little
reveal here's a little reveal it's a mess hell
big it's a mess look we did these cabinets and
then the kitchen's a mess any home person would
be so disappointed that the kitchen's a mess but
really cool stuff no the thing I wanted to show
you was this look at this I got from Etsy look at
this beautiful thing I couldn't figure out what
I wanted over here on the table and then I went
on Etsy and found this thing called a flower bar
and it comes with all these dry flowers and this
little peg board and you just put them in there
this is absolutely something you could probably
make pretty easily yourself but I did didn't
I paid someone else who made it and then they
shipped it to me and then I got to poke all the
little flowers in in my own order and make it
feel like I did it all myself I love it look how
cute that is my little brother is coming later in
the week so we got to get the house in order
everything outside is being like cleaned and
figured out um cuz I want to impress him he's
grown into quite an amazing interior designer
in his new place and I want to impress him I'm
older but I have a constant need to prove that
I'm better oh that's that's the other thing I just
ordered some pizza and some macaroni and cheese
because here let's sit down and talk about this I
talked about it on the podcast but I'll talk about
it here give you a little health update I'm doing
a lot better I'm feeling a lot better I sound I
think like I'm feeling better and that's truth
I am feeling a little bit better and it's also
misleading because they get you to a point where
you feel better and you forget about all the bad
and then they go come on in let's put you full of
some secret poisons and then we'll just you get
out of here again feeling just more fatigued this
time around and then I've had a ton of diarrhea
that's the other side of it I'm just every day
I emailed my doctor about it and he said take
two em modium every 2 hours and that should fix it
and that seems like a lot of em modium in a little
bit of time and so far it's going really well and
with that I'm going to have a gluttonous dinner
because I think I've taken enough am modium that
it shouldn't hurt me at least that's the math I'm
doing in my head about it fullon ramble vomiting
it at you vomiting I have not done with all these
side effects and that that makes me feel like I
can handle all the other ones the vomiting still
but I've been puking from a different hole um okay
that's the update I got some beautiful flowers and
I've been having constant diarrhea good morning
I just wanted to show you these new amazing Crocs
that my friend Sarah WID gifted me can you see can
you see it can you see it can you see it hello I'm
in my own car again isn't that what vlogging is
these days just people in their cars trying to
shut out the rest of the world I just got off the
phone with my brother I'm so excited he's coming
into town tomorrow I'm going to go to Trader Joe's
to try and get some snacks and stuff to stock up
for his visit I haven't been to Trader Joe's in
years but I keep seeing Tik toks of people making
food from Trader Joe's and it looks so good so
I'm going to go to Trader Joe's why have I not
gone to Trader Joe's in years is because it's too
charismatic there people are too forthright with
their RZ employees are too extroverted they see me
in a shopping environment in which I often don't
want to be seen I'd like to be invisible and their
whole purpose is to make you visible as a customer
and that is very off-putting to me but these Tik
toks look so good I know they got a lot of great
there and I've just been not allowing myself to
experience it fully out of fear so we're going to
face a stupid fear right now we're going to go
to Trader Joe's and shop around God right here
that place was crazy every aisle was full of
employees making sure that every single item
on the Shelf was perfectly aligned everyone was
blocking everything and I I could I I I panicked
and I bought a ton of [__] I don't know what it
is I don't know what goes together Trader Joe's is
not meant for browsing it is meant for people
that know where they're going are getting in
and getting out and know what they're getting
and I was not any of those things I wanted to
look around with an open mind I was like a salmon
swimming upstream and I just like chaotically put
my limbs out and grabbed whatever was available
to me and I got miso paste and some candy among
many other items I got some flowers last minute
snag some flowers and some espresso chocolate
beans we need a second to gather ourselves that
was um quite a stressful experience I think I'm
more of a Ralph's girl I think I prefer Ralph to
Joe Ralph seems like he doesn't give sh he just
throws a bunch of in the a room and says good
luck take your time hello it's Thursday another
day another psyching myself up to go out to run
a public errand where all my introverts still
feeling residual side effects of the pandemic at
hey this time the errand is a little different mry
Hart turns 40 years old tomorrow incredible mayry
Hart is also so extremely interested in wine I'm
going to try and get her a really nice bottle of
red wine I know nothing about wine that requires
me talking to someone at a wine shop and asking
them to recommend something I have another gift
for her that's absolutely chaotic and it's being
made and I thought I expedited it but I didn't
so that might get here in a few weeks and that
one is a real wild card it's not something she
needs or knows that she wants but we'll see when
it gets to that one's a little bit more creative
so we're going to in the meantime get her a really
nice bottle of wine and then we're going to go to
Target and we're going to look for board games
because my little brother gets into town later
tonight but I probably won't see him till tomorrow
because I get sleepy early these days I was
getting sleepy earlier before these days started
but now it's I'm in bed by like 8:00 humble brag
guys wine shopping total success the guy that was
in that wine shop easy peasy I didn't have to use
any of my rehearse conversation and he helped me
find I think something perfect for mamory look
how big this botle one ideal once he showed me the
novelty size wine we were all in success now let's
go find board games successful Target visit we got
Katan we got another game we got pumpkin scentered
candles and then we got tired so we came back and
we are in bed I lay in bed for a couple hours and
see where the day takes us which might be to more
bed here's the problem I got really tired when I
was shopping at Target so I was like I'm going to
come home and take take a nap saw that last night
I put out espresso bean chocolates in a little
dish cuz Elliot had a friend coming over and I
was trying to be like Hostess cute like look our
house just naturally has like some candies and
dishes around just in case oh so I came home and
I start gobbling all the espresso with chocolates
my brain's like Bing and I'm in bed with my
body tired and my brain Bing little unconscious
self-sabotaging ways but we'll be gentle on
ourselves body tired brain Bing hello vlog I
just took a shower which was lovely we haven't had
hot water for over a week and we got our hot water
tank fixed yesterday also my little brother's in
town and I took him to one of the hottest spots
here in Los Angeles last night the Cheesecake
Factory at the Americana elegant refined dining
experience on a Friday night I didn't Vlog any of
it because I wanted to spend time with my family
and not be a [__] weirdo today is now Saturday
and I slept really poorly last night and I woke
up feeling pretty icky so so my little brother I
think might come over call him I don't know why
I don't call him Tim you know Tim Tim might come
over and I think we might just chill on the couch
and watch TV today just like we used to do when we
were kids on Saturdays oh man it is disappointing
next Wednesday I get my third round of chemo
which is incredible that that's gone so fast I was
feeling like better and better and better every
day and then yesterday I woke up a little wonky
and today I woke up a little wonky and I think
just like pushing myself maybe a little bit more
than I should but look at this cute thing I got
look at that it's a glass bag and you put candy
in it how [__] cute is that hey look who's here
Tim's here guess what Tim brought with him for a
day of nesting uh a Nintendo 64 that we grew up
with and we already played some uh Pokemon Stadium
Sushi go round Sushi go round best great game ever
created greatest game ever created created he's
introducing me to a show called siren survive the
island which is insane already and we're eating
popcorn it's 3:30 on a Saturday afternoon
and we're fully nesting successful visit so
far we're here we're in Palm Springs bringing the
brother to see the highball house I didn't piss
my pants I just have sweated between my legs oh
cute yeah hi [Music] house uh-oh what's happening
here I'm cleaning he's cleaning because he's been
making soup oh my God how what a sweetie making me
soup good morning we're down here in the womb
room in Palm Springs wonder why I call it the
womb room just [__] look at it down here with my
brothers and Elliot to have a nice couple days and
it's really nice except I feel kind of crummy my
stomach isn't great here's my collection of autra
mons and I have a delicious breakfast that Elliot
just brought me of toast and bananas so having fun
just like thought I might feel a little bit better
but I got to listen to my body so we're going to
eat really boring stuff and lay down Palm Springs
is a perfect place for just laying down [Music]
goodbye we just dropped him off at the Palm
Springs Airport look at it so cool hello I've
decided I'm going to do some holiday decorating
and I bought this off of westelm yeah it looks
like a cartoon emo octopus but it's a big old
spider and I think it's sweet and hilarious but
uh update we just drove back up from Palm Springs
this morning dropped my little brother off at the
airport it was very emotional it was so nice to
see him hold on I've had a very very emotional
day today I've been crying all day today I think
it was that it was so nice to see my family my
step brother came down who lives out here in Los
Angeles but to spend time with him and Tim in
Long chunks of time which just so nice and it was
also like very confronting too because I felt sick
like I couldn't really keep up with them and we
weren't doing anything like that crazy just hang
out and I felt very tired and so it was like the
first time I felt very confronted of feeling like
very sick around people that are not sick want
to entertain and host and the urge to want to
do all these things that I just I can't really
do right now I started throwing a bit of like a
pity party for myself I also had therapy today too
it's Tuesday guys also my stomach wasn't feeling
well like you've heard this whole week I finally
did the BRAT diet thing and it really worked and
so I'm sticking to that but it's just hard to get
calories which is a little stressful and now it's
the night before we go to round three of chemo
which is amazing cuz that marks the halfway point
and it is starting to get tough emotionally yeah
like I feel weak I feel tired but I don't want to
let myself wallow in like the negatives instead I
want to recognize that this is like because we're
doing it because we're killing cancer this thing
is temporary and this is part of the process this
is what I didn't sign up for it's also a lot cuz
tomorrow is my birthday if you know me you know
I like to run out of town on my birthday and not
receive a lot of that attention I don't know why
well I do a little bit I talked about in therapy
today of receiving that kind of attention makes
me uncomfortable and man the universe is really
making me work through [__] which is kind of
cool but uncomfortable that's really what it is
I feel uncomfortable more than I feel comfortable
these days and I guess that's the [__] of
sickness and that is the mental game that you
have to manage after all these years of trying
to like run away every birthday the universe is
like no you're going to sit down on your birthday
and in fact we're going to um plug you in to some
stuff so you really cannot leave and we'll have to
be around people who will know it's your birthday
and you will have to sit there not for like a few
minutes no for hours I don't know there's a lot
of extra attention this year all of that is what
I'm working on dealing with sorry I shouldn't say
sorry that's stupid so is that I don't want to
sit here and cry but it has felt like a lot the
last couple days and I guess maybe the highlight
of it being my birthday just like puts this extra
Spotlight on it cuz I feel like I'm starting to
have to really process to deal with a lot of the
side effects some days it's totally fine and then
some days it's this week I've been really extra
emotional about it from seeing my family knowing
that they see me looking sick and looking sick I
think is the most confronting I've spent so many
years editing and crafting the way that I appear
to people on little videos and off and so when
that's out of your control you feel out of control
it's been nice to cry through it though today a
different version of me would really really hold
it in waves all emotional waves the good stuff is
that I'm going to be 38 tomorrow and we will be
halfway or starting the halfway point of uh the
chemo experience I also have that steroid in me
that I have to take the day before my chemo
sessions and that always makes me feel very
like this so when I'm feeling like this and also
emotional it feels very like spiraling suddenly so
I have to breathe but I just wanted to update
you cuz I want to update you on stuff that's
going on and also maintain some level of privacy
but I don't want to give you the illusion that
everything is so fine and good and manageable all
the time sometimes it's really emotional that's
okay it's just uncomfortable good morning it's
time for chemo day three I'm eating a sensible
banana I'm waiting on a piece of toast and we're
making some coffee for Elliot feeling a lot better
today bowels are feeling better today that's a
game changer let's go have one of the weirdest
birthdays of my adult life oh and I said this on
the podcast before but I bought crumble cookies
to give the nurses today and I'm very nervous
about it but we're going to do it we're meeting
with the oncologist today oh added activity today
Us in the restroom again before we start getting
all the you're out doctor said my blood counts
look good great birthday news it begins it is
[Music] cold uh-oh I didn't know this was
happening look at this man being cute oh my
god oh boy look what this boy just said up my God
uhoh got himself a little birthday treat today too
happy birthday thank you yay round three is over
slash it has begun woo woo and now I'm going to
eat some french fries cuz I've earned it gentle a
gentle amount of french fries oh my God this oh my
God what you know making a lemonade out of no as
my cold cap just slays behind you like it's died
of overworking today and look we got crumble
cookies deliver from Nathan and Tyler it's so
sweet and oh my god what the hell we've tried one
of these before and they're like so scary they're
insane this is so fun but that smells really good
oh sh oh my God oh my God I forgot how stupid and
insane it was there's so much smoke in the kitchen
got them all she still got lung capacity killing
it good morning it is Thursday after infusion day
three feel pretty good today we're going to go
back for hydration today but it was a really great
and exhausting day yesterday there were so many
beautiful birthday messages thank you to everyone
and Elliot made it a really sweet day even though
it was a really strange day I think I'm really
tired from all that so today let's go get
hydration I got a needle in my arm from yesterday
so weird this whole thing's so weird we are now
officially halfway and we start counting down the
infusions versus counting up how cool it feels
like starting was so long ago and yesterday we're
in hydration we decided to wear a hat today pretty
big day this one came with me this week pretty big
day no no photo back from hydration looking like
a latch key kid we just gave this little thing
a bath with our last little bit of energy and
now we're making rice and we're going to relax
probably sleep this Begins the fatigue onset and
whatever other side effects await me in this round
three of chemotherapy treatment so I'm going to go
into my Hobbit Hole of health and nourishment and
I will see you next video thanks for being here